he's Reggie Miller and you're not the
hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
joining us on the program how are you
I'm doing well Theodore how are you
doing everything's good all good all
good no complaints we were just looking
at somebody who have you seen this video
on the internet where you got a couple
of guys who were doing their Diane
Williamson impersonation it's so good
it's so good
it's so funny like his movements his
hands everything it's it's it's great
it's really really funny and we were we
were watching he's got the mannerisms
down with Xion and I I was also any
reason to criticize LeBron it feels like
and after that game the fact that people
were critical of LeBron because he wants
to mentor the young players in the game
what what world are we living in that
all of a sudden LeBron is showing
weakness or something by wanting to
mentor these younger players in the game
it's absolutely crazy that people first
of all they have too much time on their
hands to get advice about this game from
LeBron James one of the all-time greats
one of the Mount Rushmore type players
for him to give words of encouragement
how to navigate your career I know
people are always going to think that he
has ulterior motives because you know
rich Paul and the whole agency but I
think it's unbelievable that number one
he's taking time you know no one knocks
Kobe you know when Kobe was you know
working out with guys and doing all this
so why does LeBron get all the hate all
the time I just don't understand it well
you know I don't know why he's so
polarizing do you well yeah well it it
kind of started with I'm taking my
talents but even before that you know
being on the cover of Sports Illustrated
at what 16 or 17 saying that chosen one
yeah when you still have MJ in the game
I think they're kind of turned people
off a little bit but he did
choose the cover call in the chosen
world now you can say the game alright
alright ok it was a little bit
self-imposed but he gets way too much
hate for doing so much for the game and
helping these young guys out I applaud
them man and help me understand this
because soccer started this where soccer
stars would exchange jerseys after a
match it's called an exchange
JaVale McGee asked well but I don't
think Zion asked for JaVale Jersey well
I know but it seemed awkward that here's
JaVale McGee who's what 10 years 12
years older than sion and he says can I
have your Jersey and then Sion doesn't
at least go through the motions and say
to juve Maggie can I look back in the
day there is absolutely no way over
there ask MJ on the court can I have
your jersey dude but I did do I told our
ball boy hey go down there and ask as I
said ask if MJ would sign my Jersey and
it took like two hours he's like wow he
doesn't know if he's gonna sign it and I
like I had ball boy go get em Jay Magic
Larry legend I believe Charles you have
a ball boy go do it before the game or
after the game I don't like to do it in
center court and buddy up in a I just
not actually trying to like take you out
the air because I don't know what's
going to transpire during the game so I
don't know if I really want your Jersey
anyways so that's why you would try to
do it before a game Jordan made you wake
up late on purpose right of course of
course he did you know we did
Jordan never asked for one of your
jerseys do you think Jordan do you think
Jordan just has Jordans jerseys on his
wall I think he may have alleged in
magic I think those may be the only two
jerseys that MJ might have what is those
two he doesn't have like their bad blood
between mrs. Stewart and blood there
I think so yeah
I think but wasn't that great basketball
yeah but that's 30 years ago you have it
you don't go man it's hard to let it go
yeah I just don't man asking for jerseys
that's okay but you got to get something
back in return
JaVale you got it was like hey you want
majors okay now that was Pam apology hey
did you notice people picking up on a
little bran MVP bandwagon that didn't
take long after we talked about that
it's funny because I got into a
back-and-forth and it was one of our
production guys you know because he he
texted me and was like are people
watching TV basketball Jana should be
unanimous MVP I'm like what no
absolutely he'll win again
Yanis will and should win the MVP let's
state that for the record but I think
it's going to be closer than people
think
because what LeBron is doing number one
in his seventeenth year
leads the league in triple doubles of
people say well triple doubles don't
mean anything this year I was like in
his 17th year he's leading the league in
triple doubles and his team has the
second-best record and they're playing
in the better conference in my opinion
that's why I think it's going to be
closer than people think and to your
point and you mentioned this last week
the sentimental vote as well because he
has four
VPS you could make it case you could
have five or six right just like Jase
shouldn't want it every year you can
make a case LeBron should have five or
six I think a lot of people are going to
vote and you've got we see the Lakers on
national TV twice a week we never see
Milwaukee right yeah so I think those
are all factors in where I think it's
gonna be a closer vote
I still think giannis wins the MVP but
it's gonna be closer than people think
Hall of Famer Reggie Miller joining us
what game do you have this week Toronto
at Golden State hopefully Steph is back
playing he was supposed to play Sunday
he didn't so possibly he plays Thursday
Thursday for us yes would you have him
play if your Golden State absolutely
okay yeah none of your Golden State if
I'm Steph and I'm healthy yeah I want to
play has nothing to do with Golden State
I know they're precautions and all that
but if I'm healthy and I can play as a
player I want to play what do you make a
Kevin Durant saying he hasn't ruled out
in the 2020 Olympics playing he hasn't
played this year with the net I think it
would be a good test experiment for him
to see though because I think he's gonna
be ready to go by May maybe June and the
Nets tell him no I'm sure they well hey
there right in the checks I'm sure they
could but look we know katie is gonna do
what he wants to do right yeah but I
don't want him playing right now it's
like I didn't want him to try to come
back this year I just know he shouldn't
come back this year no yeah not no no
right now they're currently I believe in
the seventh spot so well you're looking
at Toronto possibly Boston in that first
round right now I think they're tied
four to three no I wouldn't come back
and Kyrie has no don't come back this
year but Olympics are went in August
yeah
Woodling your thumbs and all you're
doing is working out and playing
scrimmaging you know 303 five on five
I don't know just get a little nervous
with an injury like that trying to come
back and test yourself I'd rather I'd
really you could be coming down a flight
of stairs the same thing on an Achilles
you can so we can't take off the kid
gloves 76ers in the Lakers what could
have been the fact that the artist
formerly known as the 76ers so yeah
again we how long do we know Ben Simmons
and Joelle and beat out right we don't
in you know I I just think the whole Ben
Simmons back injury was caught a lot of
people by surprise and I think I even
said to you I think he got hurt in the
all-star game I think our game yeah and
well I don't know the severity of that
and then you got in beed who already had
a bad back and now he's out with another
injury but I don't know it feels like
the 76ers are either gonna shock us or
they're gonna flame out quickly and then
all of a sudden there's gonna be
decisions that need to be made in fill
that need to be make made in
Philadelphia well here's a bad thing for
the Sixers they are a terrible row team
and currently they're in the sixth spot
so you're gonna have to start on the
road how does that happen Oh a team that
good at home is that bad on the road and
with those type of players to me
arguably one of the best starting fives
so it's a little head scratching you've
got one of if not the premier post
player in embiid and a 16 point guard so
for them to have only won 19 games on
the road is a little bit shocking so you
would have to start on the road come to
playoffs and they've been atrocious so
but then again it's the East so if
you're Philadelphia right now that third
spot is Boston and Boston is balling so
it's Boston Toronto they're flipping
back and forth maybe they're saying
they're not scared of Toronto but
Toronto I'm telling people wake up wake
up champion a championship experience
yeah I can always say hey reg told me
first there I saw where Trevor Ariza
was not going to fall for the nutmeg by
Trey young and gave him a 4-iron shiver
I loved it from Trevor Reese's point of
view it's like no no young young guy you
know that I'm not here for your
amusement I love it because he's been
embarrassing a lot of guys now normally
you get big guys on that right when they
you know hedge out a strong show on
those high screen and rolls but to do it
to a wing player and a wing player of
trevor ariza stature a guy that you know
10 plus years in the league he's a
champion wanted with the Lakers ain't
falling for that and no one is he going
for that I like it just like here's the
thing I know everyone's talking about
Yanis and James Harden the
back-and-forth man where's my popcorn I
want more of this that's this is what an
NBA needs
yeah but did you make the John back and
forth you know criticizing each other's
games to former MVPs going at one
another yes thank you I'm here for that
yeah but it started out entertaining and
then all of a sudden the Greek freak
says hey I'm just gonna go home and
spend time with my family get a good
night's sleep and be with my child like
that's not the trash-talking that we
want we needed a little more than that
reg because it started out why saying
I'm not I didn't draft James Harden
because I wanted guys who were gonna
pass the ball and then harden comes back
with Boyd be nice to be seven feet just
run and dunk and that's all you do I
have to learn the game of basketball and
then that's when the Greek freak should
have come back and said something about
Harden and he says hey I just want to
get a good night's sleep and go home to
be with my family and my child that's
not good
would you would you want to be the first
one with the dig which giannis was or
the counter what do you want I like to
be the first digger I got in first all
you're doing is responding to me yeah
but I'm a counter puncher I like it I
don't get in I don't go early but I'll
go off and after that okay yeah well
look the game that
follow that trash-talking was 41 in 2009
Oh first 40 and 20 so I think that was
his counter punch right oh so all I do
is dunk 41 and 20
there's your counter punch I don't hold
grudges I squeezed grudges tourniquet on
them what's the longest grudge you've
ever held I don't hold it I don't hold
grudges I don't I really it's not good
for your mental health but you don't
have one against Michael Jordan no okay
why don't I start something I'm just I
get up more upset at myself because in
because we had chances and you wouldn't
you just look I just replay a lot of
things in my career against them and the
Knicks not just MJ but you just replay
your are more upset at myself do you
know not never
I just stopped recently having
basketball dreams
what do you mean I used to have them all
the time of you know my career of
playing and situations so that has kind
of subsided it's torturous man at times
it could be torturous well give me some
what are some of these nightmares
they're not nightmares they're just like
situations you know of playing against
MJ playing against Kobe you know in the
finals you know with things that we
could have done differently things I
should have done differently you just
replay things in your head that's all
sometimes it's good their therapy to
kind of dream it out or think it out and
other times you're like just shake your
head like what could have been I still
have nightmares about showing up late on
SportsCenter
how many times did that happen never did
it it never happened but you just
showing up late and you mean over men's
like ten minutes into the show and he's
like where's my partner is that what you
know I just I don't know what it is
it's um I can't find the classroom in
college which was really by design I
don't know why
it's a reoccurring nightmare but getting
to SportsCenter
or not being able to write the show in
time to get on the air it that bad has
stayed with me and I haven't done
SportsCenter and what 14 or 15 years but
man it's there it's it's always there
like do you ever have a dream where
you're showing up late you don't get to
the arena in time or the game starts
without you did you ever have that all
the time all the time or like I couldn't
tie my shoes the right way or my uniform
was left somewhere and the jump ball and
I'm looking at the coach that happens
all the time all the time we need
therapy don't lean we do a little bit I
really do I love our lives seriously I
do but you know we've been through a lot
and it's good that we have one another
that we can bounce things off Theodore
have you had surgery yes I had it on my
ankle the only surgeons do one on my
ankle and one where Otis Thorpe busted
my I had an orbital fracture and he they
had to put a plate in my eye in 96 yes
why have I had far more surgeries than
you wait what surgeons have you had I've
had four what I've had five knee
surgeries and then I had another one for
a replacement knee when you have when
you're a jumper and defensive stance
where my knees would go bad you could
have stopped it I've never been in a
defensive stance reg okay so my left
knee i I had I've had six knee
operations I had my shoulder redone had
hand surgery I surgery
broke some bones there like if you play
hard I'm the Matthew Dellavedova
I find it stop it and that's what
happens I play hard no no no no these
are like skateboarding injuries
no skateboard injuries that you were
probably going through so Thursday night
you're somehow gonna make some magic
you're gonna request from the Warriors
in Steve Kerr that Steph Curry play
please play just 20 minutes 20 minutes
that's all we're asking
yeah mate why don't you have klay
Thompson sit in with you during the
broadcast that would be awesome is clay
clay come on down Kevin Harlan and I
would love to have you great to talk to
you again reg safe travels and we'll
talk to you again next week see door and
my dad's the best in the biz or
something like that
Thank You reg that's Reggie Aloysius
Miller jr. the third